you remember the first time you came and
we worked out together listen and I'll
[__]
so that was it that was like the Heyday
I'll give you an example I said Charlie
Charlie Mack for those who do not know
Charlie Mack uh used to be World
security and Charlie Mack basically has
been in Will's life forever Charlie
tells me this is in like the beginning
of my career Kevin you got to get the
will you got to get around will you know
everybody who knows Charlie Mack they
know Charlie Mac does this
you just got to show up you just go I'm
just saying just show up
you got to be near that level of
greatness well and if you spend time if
you spend time what the [__] is you
laughing at him I'm trying to help you
well I'm trying to help you he's filming
Charlie calls me Kev will is doing Men
In Black they're filming it in New York
you got to get down here you got to come
to set to direct everybody cool but he
just got to get some of that energy you
got to get his energy I'm telling you
[__] just gonna happen
all right I mean
okay do you want me just to come
whatever I'll figure it out first time I
do we come to New York that's one of the
first times I see you on set while
that's why I got to see your big trailer
right this is two times I visited you on
set oh man this is dope as [__] look at
this trailer goddamn double decker
trailer holy [__] you had a busy day so
we talked for a second you were right
back out couldn't really do much I go
visit you on set again Will's got a
trainer with him now things have changed
she's got a personal trainer on set by
the way this is where I got the idea to
get a personal trainer and have him
travel with me Gerald Foster Foster is
in Will's gym trailer will has a gym
trailer I got the idea to get a drum
trailer I [__] will you're right I
mean the gym trailer right okay iron
sharpens iron this is what I need that's
what the [__] will had I gotta do the
same thing will
unbeknownst to him his guy's like yo go
in there in a gym trailer wheel in there
you just [__] around we going to jump
trailer the train is in there
he hit the Bell Bing
what's up man how you doing hey uh go
y'all in out
I don't understand
what you in or out you coming here
you're in My Sanctuary you don't [__]
around if you came to work or you came
to [__] do nothing you won't do
nothing in my house
I came to see
I came to see will Charlie Mac told me
come and see what you doing the set or
not yeah yeah I'll put it up
uh I get it I get down I get winning I
go I'm struggling with a set yeah okay
we got a [__] in here
what the [__] that was
I was really I was upset like I left
like I left you know I know I can't beat
him
I thought he was talking to
him he didn't even ask me how much I can
bet yeah that's a lot of play I don't
know don't play it's right for me I
think that's real
them places for will they they're not
for me